saint quentin vient de s'agrandir donc
il ya des événements nouveaux il ya des
problèmes à régler sur l'emploi il ya
peut-être des problèmes de relations
entre la communauté l'ex communauté
d'agglomération et le département la
région
on va parler de tout ça justement je
vous propose avant de commencer avant de
commencer par la politique de regarder
un sujet sur la mise en place du nouveau
saint quentin michel laugier a été réélu
ce samedi président de la nouvelle
agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines trop baptisé simplement 50 ans
habib sy elle passe de 7 à 12 communes
avec l'arrivée de plaisir les
clayes-sous-bois villepreux coignières
et maurepas l'intercommunalité compte
désormais deux cent trente mille
habitants ces nouvelles aventures parce
que c'est déjà un nouveau territoire
c'est un nouveau territoire avec
d'autres enjeux ont gardé tout
simplement
aujourd'hui nous avions trois gars sur
le territoire nous adorons cette nous
avons cette désormais c'est un grand
retour pour les villes de plaisir
maurepas et coignières qui avait quitté
en 1984 l'intercommunalité qu'on
appelait à l'époque la ville nouvelle
après trente ans d'absence maurepas donc
intègre l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines à une nouvelle agglomération
est donc déjà c'est une fierté en tant
que mort pas bien parce que j'ai
toujours cru dans cetet
intercommunalités et que c'était le sens
de l'histoire parce que c'est le même
bassin de vie avec pour la plupart des
projets structurants les onze vice
présidence ont été accordés aux élus de
la majorité l'économie est l'aménagement
du territoire reste la priorité de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la culture et
la santé sont déléguées à des
conseillers communautaires
les cinq villes en 30 héritent de postes
importants à l'exemple de joséphine
coleman ce berger qui obtient la
première vice présidence alors que
plaisir entre à peine dans saint quentin
en yvelines
je suis aussi vice président du
département avec trois délégations
important
donc je suis pas quelqu'un qui est là
pour couper des rubans je suis vraiment
quelqu'un d'actif et j'essaye
véritablement de mettre en place un
véritable travail pour l'intérêt général
un conseil d'agglomération qui ne s'est
pas déroulée sans heurts les élus de
gauche se sont estimés exclus de la
gouvernance de saint quentin en yvelines
et ont décidé de ne pas siéger et de ne
pas voter
merci à tous les quatre d'être avec nous
alors je vous présente sandrine grand
bonjour vous êtes vous êtes première
secrétaire
deux du département de baisse du
département des yvelines et et
conseiller régional michel lauzier vous
êtes président de saint quentin en
yvelines
je sais bien que le mans ce verger vous
êtes maire de plaisir vous êtes d'aucune
des nouvelles arrivantes dans cette
saint quentin en yvelines dont vous êtes
première vice présidente et jean michel
fourgous maire d'elancourt entière
députés alors j'ai peut-être commencé
avec vous de joséphine comme en super-g
puisque vous êtes la nouvelle arrivée
qu'est ce que est ce que c'est important
pour une ville comme plaisir d'entrer
dans cette communauté de saint quentin
en yvelines et qu'est ce que vous en
attendez j'aurais plutôt tendance à dire
plutôt de dire plutôt que de dire qu'est
ce que j'attends pur plaisir je dirais
plutôt voilà quel bille à la porte et on
vient faire quelque chose à saint
quentin c'est à dire que on a dans le
panier de la mariée si je peux me
permettre une ville dynamique surtout en
développement économique et commercial
et je pense que c'est un atout pour pour
l'intercommunalité d'arriver au niveau 2
de cette agglomération qui est une
agglomération de grande renommée de
grande réussite
je pense qu'on a on a certainement
quelque chose à faire ensemble le regard
aussi extérieure et nouveau que nous
apportons peut aussi être un atout pour
cette intercommunalité qui a 40 ans
d'existence et et de comme je disais et
d'ambition encore eh bien on vient
apporter aussi la nôtre je crois que les
cinq villes en 30 sont véritablement
dans cette dynamique là c'est à dire une
ouverture pour pouvoir avoir une
ambition encore supplémentaire avec nos
compétences et nos possibilités
alors vous disiez dans le sujet qu'on
vient de voir je suis pas là pour couper
des rubans vous êtes chargé d'ailleurs
du projet quel va être votre rôle et
comment comment s'intègre quand même
parce que les autres
l'habitude de travailler ensemble le
projet de territoire et quelque chose je
crois pour avoir échangé avec aussi bien
les villes historiques que les villes
entrant est quelque chose qui est
attendu un projet de territoire ce n'est
ni plus ni moins qu'une feuille de route
tracée pour pouvoir avoir une
prospective enfin quelque chose de pas
uniquement sur les deux trois années à
venir mais sur les 15 20 ans qui
viennent et je pense que on est à au
tournant je dirais d'une création par
cette intercommunalité nouvelle de cette
possibilité de repenser à ce projet de
territoire
donc c'est dans cette dans cette
dynamique là que je vais m'occuper
modestement bien sûr aux côtés de michel
et puis des autres de ce projet de
territoire avec une transversalité
totale puisque je crois que les douze
communes sont particulièrement je dirais
intéressé ni attendent cette feuille de
route nécessaire surtout parce que comme
vous le savez vous nous avons des
difficultés financière excessivement
arrange parce que bien sûr de france à
vouloir dévoiler ce que vous allez
évoqué là dessus et vous dire que
justement il doit avoir
on doit avoir cette ambition de pouvoir
faire de grandes choses des choses
encore mieux avec des moyens moindres
est très très compliqué puisque
aujourd'hui on nous étrangle un peu il
faut quand même avoir parlé oui parce
que seuls seront difficiles évidemment
le rôle d'élu michel logis justement cet
agrandissement de de la communauté enfin
l'ex communauté de saint quentin de
saint quentin en yvelines a mad movies
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ça
apporte à ce qu'est ce que ça vous donne
une force supplémentaire évidemment on a
vu démographiquement il ya plus
d'habitants
mais qu'est ce que ça apporte aux
habitants voilà où au jour le jour
alors qu'est-ce que sa pop aux habitants
déjà c'est une continuité pour certains
et de nouveautés pour d'autres
simplement aujourd'hui on est une
nouvelle agglomération
voilà moi je joue aujourd'hui j'appuie
là dessus nous sommes des nouvelles
agglomérations
nous sommes passés de 146 mille à 230
mille habitants aujourd'hui nous
représentons 145 mille emplois c'est à
dire qu'en région ile de france ça
compte énormément mêmes et même en
france nous avons un territoire
aujourd'hui qui est composé dont de ces
douze villes
nous avons cette gare bientôt huit avec
celles prévues dans le cadre du grand
paris donc représente un potentiel
énorme et toutes les communes
aujourd'hui qui font partie de ce
territoire ont aussi des capacités
encore assez développé se développer au
niveau démographique
on va reconstruire audhuy à logements et
se développer aussi au niveau économique
parce qu'on va encore accueillir de
nouvelles entreprises
il est sage dire le poids économique est
important surtout depuis que l'état se
désengage au niveau des collectivités
locales il faut bien qu'on retrouve au
nouveau périmètre fiscal
en tout cas si cette dynamique virtuose
nous que nous souhaitons en rappelant
aussi que nous sommes un territoire
universitaire et que le lien qui sera
indispensable avec le plateau de saclay
c'est toute la dynamique nouvelle qu'on
souhaite donner sur le territoire du
nouveau saint quentin alors on va parler
de jute des cadillac jean michel
fourgous dans un instant mais sandrine
gang
alors on a vu tout à l'heure le la
gauche le parti socialiste notamment à
refuser enfin s'est retiré des
vice-présidents sont jusqu'à présent il
y avait des vice-présidents de
l'opposition vous avez préféré vous
retirer pour pourquoi pas qu'on s'est
retirée enfin je contrôle de michel juge
ne nous a pas proposé de rentrer dans le
nouvel exécutif ne courait pas tout à
fait pareil et on tournerait accepté
bien volontiers parce que ça a été
rappelé par joséphine que ce manager on
est sur un point un projet de territoire
avant tout où il ya douze villes c'est à
vendre les étiquettes politiques c'est
d'abord 12 villes avec des des habitants
qui service desquels on doit agir quelle
que soit notre étiquette politique mais
là on était dans une période on est dans
une période de transition de toute façon
et on a voulu marquer aussi que notre
notre avis on rentrait pas complètement
normalement dans cette nouvelle ère pour
un saint quentin donc c'était aussi
notre manière de marquer notre défiance
après lac la confiance ça se construit
donc
donc tout est ouvert évidemment tout
étonné alors avant d'aborder peut-être
les problèmes économiques parce que
c'est la préoccupation principale de
tous les français et des habitants de ce
territoire notamment l'emploi quand même
qu'on adore
problème justement dit beaucoup qu'en
france il ya un millefeuille
administratif énorme et là c'est vrai
qu'on a 50 ans rivlin communauté
d'agglomération il ya le département il
ya la région est ce qu'on a besoin
d'abord de tous ces échelons et comment
on joue entre ces flots juste je
voudrais répondre quand même à scinder
des grandes orgues pour dire quand même
que toutes les communes se sont
associées à la gestion
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui aucune
délibération de la communauté
d'agglomération ne peut être prise sans
la présence de l'ensemble des
représentants des villes
la gauche y est présente dans le bureau
de l'agglomération et bien sûr aux
conseils et bien sûr la gauche étaient
présentes dans l'ensemble des
commissions et dans les organismes de
représentation à l'extérieur dont il
faut pas non plus avoir un message
erronné simplement c'est uniquement le
problème aujourd'hui des responsabilités
au niveau des vice présidences sinon sur
tout le reste
les choses se sont partagés et
d'ailleurs il ya un conseil des maires
qui eux qui va toujours se mettre en
place et qui associe l'ensemble des
tentes et tout ce maire sur les grandes
orientations stratégiques de 50 ans
décline pour en revenir à votre question
maintenant simplement c'est dire que
nous savez nous sommes des élus locaux
et c'est vrai que on est déjà habitué
depuis longtemps a travaillé comme une
intercommunalité
donc c'est vrai que ce couple là
maintenant il fonctionne il est
indissociable et il fonctionne bien et
on va essayer qui fonctionne encore
mieux avec les villes qui nous
rejoignent qui n'ont pas forcément le
même culture que nous mais je pense que
ils sont jolis seville la demande
je rappelle quand même déjà que ces
villes souhaité rejoindre le périmètre
de saint quentin
il y avait déjà quelques années dans le
cadre du schéma départemental de
coopération intercommunale donc on a
perdu quelques années c'est bien ce que
j'avais dit un moment donné mais
aujourd'hui c'est fait ya une volonté
vraiment partagé ensuite happer ya les
compétences qui sont donnés mais après
c'est au niveau législatif que les
choses se font il ya un département qui
est aussi indispensable dans le lien
parce que l'action sociale par exemple
mais ça dépend du département et là
aussi il faut qu'ils de proximité et
puis ya là il y a
région ile-de-france et le poids de
cette région alors en plus avec on
attend beaucoup depuis cette alternance
et en attend beaucoup de valérie
pécresse pour que elle travaille encore
plus avec les collectivités de des
yvelines est donc là dessus on voit que
les rôles sont très partagés mais c'est
vrai que il faudrait revenir surtout est
ce qui est des compétences précises pour
chaque niveau de responsabilité parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya trop de compétences
se croiser trois aimerait exactement
elle propose par exemple c'est vrai que
là on entend par exemple qui peut être
une fusion entre le département des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
il ya des projets comme ça il ya la
région avec une nouvelle présidente est
ce que tout ça c'est peut s'harmoniser
facilement ou est ce que comme comme le
dit michel logis faudrait pas quand même
définir les compétences et peut-être
supprimer un échelon
non mais je suis aurifères des écoles
billy's l argent public sur l'économie
bon aujourd'hui
bon vous avez vu on était très belle
boîte dans 50 indiscutablement bon il
faut se d'abord se centrer sur un
univers mondialisé
si vous voulez aider ces entreprises à
développer si vous les bons donc
aujourd'hui de toute façon faut faut
voir grand voir grand c'est bien sûr
voir d'abord l'europe quel est ce que
l'europe peut nous aider dans nos
projets est ce que le gouvernement aussi
bon est ce que l'arrivée de madame
pécresse impacte considérablement bien
sûr nos projets dans le monde mais sont
dans le bon sens pour moi en tout cas le
département comme le dit michel laugier
une nation donc il faut que toutes ces
organisations fonctionnent ensemble
c'est déjà un élément très important
pour faire gagner 50 1 demain c'est
cette équipe en même temps il ya une
question de culture il faut aussi que
tout le monde comprenne que la
mondialisation il faut l'accepter
déjà s'il ya ce qu'ils acceptent ceux
qui la combattent bon il faut aussi se
mettre d'accord si on veut vraiment
relancer l'économie je vous rappelle que
en un taux de croissance quasiment
autour de 3 sur les quatre dernières
années
les anglais c'est cinq fois plus donc de
toute façon la concurrence est
aujourd'hui non demain encore plus on
doit travailler en équipe aux différents
étages que nous avons est d'abord on
doit faire évoluer la culture française
on doit faire rentrer des capitaux qui
doivent s'investir sur les plus belles
bois que les start up que nous avons on
a un maillage de deux génies dans
rendant dans dans cet espace qui est
extraordinaire donc il faut que les
chercheurs reçoive des soutiens en ce
moment il ya une chute des soutiens il
faut qu'on renforce et soutien pour nos
chercheurs qui travaillent avec nos pme
il faut qu'on aide les différentes
étapes du petit qui arrive quand on est
à définir son son prototype jusqu'à
celui qui bien sûr comment ça pas
dépasser les 50 personnes oui il faut
que tous ces états sont les alimenter
tout ça avec les partenaires dont nous
allons parler
donc c'est quand même c'est quand un
maillage et je pense que c'est la
subtilité de ce maillage qui va faire
qu'on va passer encore à l'étape
supérieure et qu'on va réussir notamment
l'université du futur qui rentreraient
dans le top 20 mondial de shanghai
et puis en même temps ce pipe ce pipe de
2,7 de ce territoire qui doit rester un
très bon exemple qui doit être renforcée
mais attention on dépend de ce maillage
c'est la qualité de ce marché national
bien sûr le national au siège 1 le
gouvernement si a son rôle à jouer il
faut il faut bien sûr alléger la
fiscalité pour refaire revenir les
capitaux dont nous avons terriblement
besoin
il faut simplifier bien sûr la vie des
entrepreneurs notamment ce code du
travail que vous connaissez on en parle
toute la journée
si vous vous êtes bloqué ou vous avez un
plafond à 35 heures de programmes de 35
heures en france
vous avez parlé de travail -
vingt-quatre heures après vous avez des
murs à l'intérieur vous allez pénibilité
etc
vous avez quatre cents 400 milles
réglementation qui s'abattent aussi
essentiellement sur trouver de bouc donc
il faut des zestes fixiez tout ça et si
on arrive à faire tout cela je peux vous
dire que la france la france saint
quentin et sanglante on doit être le
laboratoire de dexter accélérateur de
croissance un modèle en france il peut
l'être
à condition bien sûr qu'on modification
des choses des facteurs de cette
excellence aura de 50 à celle incubateur
qui va être créée ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire d'attirer de nouvelles
entreprises des jeunes entreprises des
start up
alors d'abord quand vous êtes quand vous
avez une idée un c1 de rien on parle des
idées c'est bien mais avant d'arriver à
l'entreprise bon donc il ya deux ans
vous prenez le gars vous le mettez en
incubateur vous l'aidez à conceptualiser
aaa
à faire son prototype même de services
voulus à chercher des partenaires parce
que tout seulement voilà et vous l'aider
à trouver des talents premier talent
d'un dirigeant ça doit être de trouver
des talents autour de lui donc tout ça
il sait pas donc on ya deux ans de
maturation de son projet de trouver un
banquet de trouver bien sûr ça il faut
une entreprise c'est la rencontre entre
une idée un gars qui a de l'argent du
capital
un gars qui a un réseau commercial un
gars qui sait produire d'envoyer l'aider
à faire monter ce tour de table et ça
peut durer entre un an et deux ans et
après on le passe à othman 9 euros chez
promo paul où là il ya un peu plus de
place où c'est une autre phase de
maturité et la troisième phase on le
reprend en main et on lui trouve des
locaux dans bien sur le territoire de
saint quentin volley et trois phases
pour dynamiser nos jeunes entrepreneurs
un mot sur votre fonction au fond parce
que vous le disiez tout à l'heure aux
faux il voyait beaucoup moins d'argent
l'ailé
l'état n'a plus d'argent dans quelle
voie qu'est ce que c'est votre rôle
aujourd'hui le rôle des élus cesser de
gérer la pénurie
si vous permettez que vous aviez posé
une quand même question précis c est ce
qu il ya un méchant de trop dans le
mille feuilles le coup moi je peux
peut-être le dire parce que je suis pas
comme mes collègues conseillers
départementaux mais je pense qu'en
ile-de-france ces départements sont de
trop je pense que le gouvernement a fait
une erreur en allant pas jusqu'au bout
de sa logique
je conçois qu'il faille garder des
départements dans des zones rurales en
ile de france on a la métropole dans la
région et on va avoir des grosses
intercommunalités je pense que saint
quentin en fait étant une étape
intermédiaire parce que c'est un
territoire qui a vocation à s'élargir on
avait eu ce débat sur le plateau de
saclay forcément on aura une
agglomération qui sera abandonné plus
conséquente que ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
donc pour moi le département et et de
toutes façons de trop et on voit le jour
de dépasser aujourd'hui les difficultés
qu'il a assumé son rôle en parliez de
pression fiscale je crois que vous avez
peut-être pas vous mais voter
l'augmentation des impôts de manière
très forte sur le département il ya des
services publics il faut maintenir quand
ils ont du mal visiblement à maintenir
et on est dans une période qui je ne dis
pas que c'est simplement le cas du
département des yvelines mais il ya un
vrai souci et
et dernière chose que je voulais dire
parce que ça dans le vocabulaire c'est
pas notre et c'est pas tout à fait le
même sujet mais monsieur fukui par les
dégâts quand on parle entrepreneurs et
aussi des filles 1
cette info le manga était attablé d'eric
jésus sorte 6 millions et demi de
chômeurs je le rappelle il ya des choses
importantes aujourd'hui les mots sont
importants mais il ya six millions et
demi de chômeurs a peut-être passé aussi
au jeu un autre chose vraiment voilà
justement est-ce que sur les
départements pour ces capteurs ben il va
falloir il va falloir les supprimer ou
pas
écoutez si vous allez pour le moment ce
qui se passe c'est que nous avons
plusieurs niveaux de responsabilité pour
jeudi
déjà il faudrait de clarification dans
les compétences et qu'on ne marche pas
toujours sur les mêmes plates bandes en
fonction du département de la région
il faut qu'on souffre faut qu'on soit il
faut être à l'évidence aujourd'hui il y
aura forcément une structure en trop et
c'est bien évidemment il va falloir que
on y travaille autrement ou alors il
faut avoir d'autres d'autres ambitions
d'autres ambitions pour les pour les
territoires aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on
réfléchit beaucoup
un rapprochement avec le département des
hauts-de-seine
ces pactes et aujourd'hui on va
travailler ensemble déjà pour savoir
comment on peut faire comme membre ça
pourrait voilà jean michel par les deux
expérimentations mais nous aussi nous en
somme elle a sonné au niveau des
départements pour essayer aussi de
trouver de notre oxygène
parce que sandrine oublie de dire
qu'avec que si le département des
yvelines est obligé d'aller vers une
augmentation significative de la taxe
foncière
c'est tout simplement parce qu'il ya des
engagements historiques de l'état ses
140 millions en moins ça et recollait
tout assure néanmoins 140 millions en
moins en trois ans c'est à dire que on
va perdre tout de dotation générale de
fonctionnement le haut niveau du
département des yvelines
on aura plus dans dans deux ans de
dotation générale de fonctionnement et
en plus comme c'est un département qui a
été bien gérée qui est peu fiscalisés
que au niveau du bourg nous on se dit
ils ont les capacités de pouvoir
augmenter leur taxe puisque les taxes se
sont plu parce qu'ailleurs c'est à dire
que c'est la double peine puisque
aujourd'hui si vous gérez bien vous êtes
pénalisé dans c'est un petit peu cette
injustice là aussi qu'il faut dire mais
on n'a pas d'autre choix en tant qu'élu
conçoit mer qu'on soit conseiller
départemental où qu'on soit dans une
intercommunalité
od soumis exactement aux mêmes
problématiques et ode à la même morale a
dit qu'au niveau de notre
intercommunalité puisque nous devons
faire mieux ou au moins aussi bien avec
beaucoup moins avec eux bookmakers
voilà on a des charges qui sont de plus
en plus élevés mais par contre on a des
recettes qui sont de moins en moins
élevé dont je peux dire que on a une
équation qui est de plus en plus
difficile et aujourd'hui nous sommes des
élus
notre notre rôle aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir dire non est de savoir expliquer
pourquoi nous disons non parce qu'être
lui quand il ne faut dire que oui ça
c'est très facile nous aujourd'hui
c'était peut être le cas il ya quelques
années où je dis entrons dans une phase
des élus qui doivent dire non
est-ce que c'est plus grison est ce que
c'est plus frustrant c'est réduit
aujourd'hui le cas c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué et mais par contre là c'est
vrai que c'est un véritable rôle d'élu
on doit faire des choix et des choix
souvent difficiles à faire et pas
forcément des choix que l'on ait vu
faire dans ces conditions là ça va ça va
évidemment affluer le projet le manque
d'argent
évidemment on va avoir une influence sur
le projet de saint quentin
automatiquement bien sûr mais quels sont
les choix est ce qu'il ya des choix
comme ça que l'on vous dit c'est évident
qu'il faut couper dans telle ou telle
dépense
non non aujourd'hui on peut pas se
permettre de dire qu'il ya des choix qui
sont des évidences il ya des compétences
obligatoires comme le rappelait le
président et puis il ya ce que évoqué
jean michel fourgous sur le
développement de l'emploi
et puis de l'économie qui est la base
même je dirais de tout enracinement de
quelque chose d'ambitieux sur un
territoire si on n'a pas ça c'est pas le
nerf de la guerre on pourra pas
fonctionner c'est une évidence
je reviendrai un tout petit peu si vous
le permettez à ce que vous évoquez tout
à l'heure sur justement les strates
ce qui est important de savoir c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on est véritable
dans ses réflexions là c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on n'attend pas de l'état
qu'il met en place une réforme
territoriale pour nous dire qu'elle est
la strate qui va disparaître
aujourd'hui on est véritablement en
accroche avec la région et pour cause
avec valérie pécresse orné aussi nous on
travaille sur l'intercommunalité les
collectivités le département pour
justement se regrouper se mettre
ensemble pour voir qu'est ce qu'on doit
faire
déjà ce niveau là avant même que l'état
puisse prendre une décision claire et
nette sur la réforme territoriale qui
n'a jamais été fait depuis de nombreuses
années qu'on attend désespérément mais
nous je peux vous dire qu'on travaille
là-dessus
aujourd'hui on est en train de
travailler pour savoir comment on va
pouvoir réformer les choses à notre
niveau avec ses différentes strates pour
trouver des sources d'économies et de
fonctionnement pour faire mieux avec
moins
comme vous le disiez donc on devient de
vrais gestionnaires dire qu'aujourd'hui
les élus locaux doivent jongler avec
cette proximité nécessaire absolument
nécessaire que la population attend
puisque ces strates automatiquement
augmente
l'éloignement de la population donc il
faut retrouver cette proximité
c'est-à-dire cette écoute et en même
temps avoir ce côté gestionnaire qui
fait que à la limite on est pratiquement
des chefs d'entreprises parce qu'on est
obligés de gérer nos problématiques
financières et de faire des prospectives
à long terme donc tout ça le projet de
territoire si appuiera bien sûr et puis
toutes les actions qu'on va faire au
niveau des différentes activités sur le
sur le territoire justement c'est une
grande honte quand on entend dire voilà
les humains dans sept des gestionnaires
à ce que au fond l'engagement politique
passe pas au deuxième plan non je crois
justement que ce que vient d'expliquer
aussi vient me chercher que je suis une
kossmann berger celle inverse et ircam
en donner encore plus qu'avant les choix
qui vont être faits sont primordiaux que
on continue sur la lancée avec le
président actuel ou un autre ou un
président de droite en 2007 on sait que
ça sera de toute façon financièrement
soit pareil donc donc la question c'est
effectivement la question des choix et
c'est là où on peut avoir des
divergences en fonction des
appartenances politiques
on l'a vu sur le dernier budget où nous
ont considéré qu'il fallait absolument
ne pas lâcher des secteurs comme la
culture notamment la culture tout le
tissu associatif
voilà c'est des films des débats sur le
meilleur mais au contraire c'est donc
parce que il y a besoin d'avoir des
propositions claires que peut-être plus
que jamais on a là on est devant des
choix politiques et sur la vous disiez
que sur la réforme territoriale
elle n'a pas eu lieu si elle a eu lieu
puisque la l'agrandissement de 50 ans
c'est le résultat justement des lois que
le gouvernement a fait voter la loi de
matane et lalanne ou un autre par contre
là où je suis critique si je pense
qu'effectivement il n'est pas allé assez
loin dans sa réflexion mais on a bien
une réforme territoriale qui est en
marche après il faut du temps et c'est
là où peut-être que nos concitoyens
encore plus de mal que nous ne sait déjà
pas toujours très simple mais alors pour
les concitoyens j'imagine que pour se
repérer c'est pas évident jean michel
fourgous quelque chose qui fait aussi
éclaté le l'estrade géographique
habituel c'est le plateau paris saclay
où fo qui tous proches dissidents dans
lequel le territoire et est partie
prenante a opté de débord juillet à
saint lon sur ces cumuls de ce tract là
à quoi sert le grand paris on est chauds
pas très bien compris cela dit bon mais
c'est pour ça deuxièmement fusion autres
départements ain 2e attention à ce mythe
de l'interco vous savez en france on est
un pays extrêmement centralisé
extrêmement économie administrée ou là
et on n'arrive pas nous faire croire que
c'est en créant de nouvelles strates
qu'on va régler le problème en fait le
résultat de les intercoms c'est plus les
fait grossir plus les élus sont
dépouillés leur pouvoir et plus
l'administration s'empare du
du pilotage et ça c'est une logique très
franco-française très très administratif
c'est de l'économie administrée et donc
attention il faut laisser de la liberté
aux élus je vous rappelle que le mandat
il ya un sondage qui sort houleux où le
maire est au top
oui et la fonction nationale et voir le
président est au plus bas
bon voilà pourquoi pas ce que c'est il
faut on demande un état de proximité
maintenant sur votre question sur paris
ces clubs ont bien sûr tout on a compris
que vous êtes dans une zone
exceptionnelle puisque on était classé
par le mi6 dans les huit zones mondial
de l'innovation et on est très content
de voir le crédit impôt recherche cela
dit au passage parce que c'est aussi
avec ceux cette protection d'ukrainiens
brochage qu'on a pu garder le chercheur
sion avec la fiscalité de massacres
qu'on a eu
il allait partir donc c'est bien on a
gardé nos chercheurs on a les plus
belles entreprises ont bien sûr paris
saclay c c'est donc l'espace
exceptionnel mondial dans l'es8
exception mondiale
et là effectivement de faire travailler
les chercheurs les plus grandes écoles
hec polytechnique
toutes les plus belles d'établissements
d'enseignement super que nous avons bien
sûr c'est un enjeu est exceptionnel avec
les plus belles boîtes parce que ici a
souvent les plus belles boîtes du côté
de saclay vous avez beaucoup de
laboratoires dont deux de faire
travailler en synergie ces gens là alors
à condition qu'on trouve de l'argent je
vous dis c'est pour ça qu'ils aient
choisi de l'argent alors il faut il faut
aussi rétablir une fiscalité normale on
a une fille ce cas normal en france on
est on est plus compétitif donc il faut
leur devenir
pour faire bien massivement le
capitalisme il faut se réconcilier avec
le capitalisme une bonne fois pour
toutes si on ne gagnera pas cette zone
on peut la rendre exceptionnel à
condition qu'on nous laisse faire venir
des capitaux fait revenir des talents
par exemple on a besoin aussi de bien
seuls les universitaires les grands
chercheurs les grands profs ils
viendront parce que deux monstres un
campus de 70000 personnes
donc c'est ça c'est ça paris saclay
cession des milices et là vous pouvez
faire venir
l'élite de l'élite et c'est comme ça
qu'on gagne 1 c'est par le haut qu'on
gagne et le bas ils montrent tout seul
après mais c'est par le haut vous faites
d'abord venir ceux qui savent ce qu'ils
sont entrepreneurs ceux qui ont des
moyens
je vous rappelle que la croissance et du
capital du travail et de l'intelligence
le capital c'est pas terrible la
fiscalité en france 1 deuxièmement le
travail c'est pas terrible avec les 35
heures avec la pénibilité et toutes ces
conneries
contre l'intelligence il faut le
reconnaître c'est pas mal on a su quand
même protégé même les socialistes la
seule chose qu'ils aient compris c'est
peut-être ça encore qu'il a fallu se
battre pour défendre le crédit
impôt-recherche mais effectivement
mettre l'intelligence qui est pas mal
donc il faut la protéger mais si on
arrive à redresser un peu tout ça
effectivement cette zone peut être la
silicon valley demain vous pouvez avoir
le harvard français on est on peut être
capable de créer le harvard français
dans cette zone là oui voilà avant que
vous lui répondre non enfin ces débats
au pas très intéressante juste sur le
sera pas là on a un accord c'est
qu'effectivement ce territoire il est
absolument essentiel et c'est pour ça
que nous on avait défendu dans un
premier temps une intercommunalité qui
englobait le plateau de saclay passe
comme vous l'avez évoqué il ya pas de
coupure la coupure départemental avec
les soldes n'a pas tu n'as pas de sens
et on est bien sur un territoire qui
vont très bien ensemble pour ça qu'on
voit bien qu'on est sur des sur des
découpages qui ne correspondent plus à
rien un mot allah pour conclure sur le
territoire justement ce que vous disiez
il ya des choses exceptionnelles quand
même on est dans cette un territoire qui
est commun dans une situation plus
favorable que le reste de la france ce
serait ce qu'au point de vue il ya moins
un peu moins de chômage etc
alors avec les difficultés comme parce
qu'on est dans une situation qui est
difficile est ce que vous êtes tous les
uns et les autres
plutôt optimistes ou dit ça sera dur si
on est élu ses codes optimiste tu as
c'est la première chose parce que en
plus je reviens ce que tous les propos
qui ont été tenus par par des collègues
là à l'instant le maire est apportée
d'engueulades c'est l'élu local le plus
proche
voilà donc que seydou aussi qui te font
donner le bon tempo à notre population
dont déjà sillonné lui sur des élues
locales
on a envie de se battre et dont on
connaît un optimiste et non plus
aujourd'hui dans cette nouvelle
intercomités dans sa nouvelle
configuration
je peux vous dire que il ya beaucoup
d'attentes de la part des arrivants et
moi j'en suis très heureux parce que
c'est une volonté commune que nous avons
de réussir ce nouveau territoire
chacun a ses atouts et ont réuni ses
atouts
vrai qu'aussi il n'y a pas que des
atouts ona 40000 personnes aujourd'hui
qui sont dans des quartiers politique de
la ville mais c'est aussi notre notre
rôle notre action mais c'est vrai que
c'est en trouvant de nouveaux périmètres
fiscaux de nouvelles richesses qu'on va
pouvoir encore aider beaucoup mieux les
autres en tout cas nous notre volonté
c'est d'être performant dans toutes les
compétences qui sont les nôtres et je
peux vous dire que au nahd de l'ambition
dont chacune des communes et à chacune
des douze communes de saint quentin en
yvelines
on sait qu on a aussi beaucoup de
projets je travaillais hier avec le berr
de magny les hameaux aussi sur un
développement économique potentiel
j'avais ce matin le maire de guyancourt
et on parlait justement de la ligue 18
et de la gare qui pourrait se trouver
donc sur guiro cours dont vous voyez on
travaille chaque fois qu'on se voit
c'est vraiment pour évoquer l'avenir
dans les meilleures conditions parce que
on ya toujours un territoire attractif
et je dire chaque commune peut en
témoigner
on est souvent sollicité par des
promoteurs pour construire pas des
promoteurs aussi qui veulent installer
des entreprises sur notre sur notre
territoire et puis surtout aussi
aujourd'hui on a la chance de pouvoir
être en relation directe avec le
département avec le conseil régional
pour l'aménagement des routes et l'état
d'un nous suit plus ou moins mais en
tout cas est toujours attentif à la
parole de portée par saint quentin en
yvelines
justin mottier d'actualité la démission
de christiane taubira c'est plutôt une
cohérence pour gouvernement plutôt à
titre personnel moi j'ai eu l'occasion
de rencontrer
quelquefois c'est une femme absolument
extraordinaire parce que femme de
culture c'est pas souvent qu'on voit des
hommes et des femmes politiques capables
de citer dans le texte de rené char aimé
césaire mais après voilà il faut être
cohérent politique je crois qu'elle
avait pu se trouvait plus sa place donc
c'est plutôt bien pour elle qu'elle soit
sortie est juste parce que sur le losc
que c'est dur ou pas durer excusez moi
je change de dessus
gg en commun avec un de vos chroniqueurs
d'être sûr trappe d'être élu à trappes
et quand vous on a une population sont à
part les entreprises tard mais aussi des
habitants on a une population très jeune
attrapez on a une population qui plein
de talent on le voit aussi dans
l'actualité régulièrement et franchement
quand vous êtes au contact de ces gens
là ça donne la pêche
pour continuer c'est bien un bon jean
michel fourgous vous l'avez lu ses
livres de sarkozy ya non pas encore mais
femmes et d'enfants le lit refrain vous
partage les normes et non je sais que je
peux le dire julien juste avant les
primaires ça va pas vous séparer les uns
et les autres
écoutez les primaires c'est un choix qui
a été fait démocratiquement où c'est
souvent dire quand la droite c'est des
primaires on est divisés quand la gauche
fait des primaires c'est la démocratie
bon voilà et si on pouvait d'ailleurs
revenir un peu à un vocabulaire vous
qu'il soit le plus c'est parce que vous
avez dit ah mais je l'entends souvent ça
écoutez moi je trouve ça très sain que
des aulas qu'on désigne un chacun
défendra son point de vue son programme
voilà donc dont que médecins plongent à
leur sauce ce que j'entendais tout à
l'heure quand même c'est que bien sûr
qu'on vit quand même moment difficile
en fait on va quasiment avoir une baisse
de 20 à 30% de nos moyens dans les
collectivités
c'est bien sûr une situation extrêmement
grave un jeu madame le grande disette
leur conte et augmenter les impôts
bon on a simplement appliqué l'impôt
allant de on a pas on n'augmente pas ou
n'est ce pas on applique simplement les
transferts d'impopularité fiscale
commander mais -20% -30% sur le budget
de fonction c'est énorme donc est il
donc si on risque d'avoir une baisse de
20% de nos de notre service public donc
deux on va peut-être vous imaginez on
est dans des opportunités hypothèse on
va baisser peut être il ya des gens qui
vont qui vont fermer des écoles et des
piscines des ddd des crèches
donc faut bien faut bien rappeler qu' on
est dans l'initiation et deuxièmement au
niveau économique
et puisqu'il y associe les questions bas
au niveau économique attention en vous
entendu souvent parler du décrochage
économique
alors est ce qu on sait ce que c'est le
décrochage comme c'est simple c'est très
simple vous avez 45 % de dépenses
publiques en allemagne et vous en avez
58 en france
si on ne règle pas ce problème l'un de
toute façon là ça va mal se passer en
france
économiquement on pourra plus rien faire
parce que vous ne pouvez pas rester dans
votre boîte peut pas récent mais quand
vous avez 13 points de décrochage
économique dont deux façons on est tous
obligés de se pencher sépare de votre
question soyez sûr lesbien sur les
successions de structure elle est
centrale s'est il réjoui votre dernière
question je suis passé je sais pas
gentilles non j'ai aussi entendu une
chose c'est que par exemple pour trappe
trappe c'est bien ce que vous faites
parce qu'il ya ya ya trois mille 900
chômeurs attrape c'est un record dans
l'histoire de trappes donc on doit on
doit s'emparer de sa gelée mesure qui
était la plus qu'elle était la plus
créatrice d'emplois attrape ses c'est la
zone franche urbaine stères de baisser
la fiscalité pour attirer ces sacrés
savait créer 1000 emplois marchands
mille emplois publics et je veux dire
j'en est à l'origine de cette mesure
mais cela dit aujourd'hui c'est une
catastrophe on à 3900 ces jeunes on doit
s'en occuper vous avez par les jeunes
c'est fondamental on doit trouver de
nouveaux dispositifs et pas des
tuyauteries là qu'on finisse plus de
démagogie et de et d'opérations comme
des vraies mesures qui donnent envie aux
entreprises qui qui qui est adapté aux
bien sûr au développement il faut
trouver un moyen tous ensemble il faut
qu'on sorte rap de cette situation parce
que c'est pas durable merci merci à tous
les quatre